how long did it take you to learn all
the dialogue months months because
you're learning spanish spanish right
and it was uh so can you speak any of it
now do you remember any of it
that's the line i remember pretty cool
pretty good thank you sounds great so i
uh so he gave me the option to just like
you know
give the right count to 10 like he said
but i knew
i couldn't give him
lip movement going one two three four
five six seven eight nine 10.
and then try to dub over that with lips
not matching that would have been ugly
and then also you're playing i was
playing opposite a an eleven-year-old
actress who
needed something more from me than one
through ten right
right you know what i'm saying yes of
course i mean i would have been a
disservice to her into the scene to the
scenes
to uh count was he very grateful that
you did all that
i i believe so i um
i just i showed up knowing it all so
thank heaven but i will say
as hard as it was to memorize dialogue
in a language you don't speak
once you do know it
it comes out of you the same every time
because in english when you're
memorizing english dialogue uh your
native tongue you have a vocabulary full
of options right right so uh
you know like this uh
oh what would uh adjectives and adverbs
are where where we get i get hung up on
like when things will come out because i
have so many options to pull from right
which was it again uh uh uh but in
spanish uh or i also did a movie in
french the same way i played a creature
uh
version of of serge gainsbourg as his
alter ego and that and friend same thing
i once once it's in there it's in there
that one way and you have no options so
it comes out the same every time so
thank heaven for that just took it just
took a minute to get it in there but you
had experience was it was it um surfer
the uh the silver surfer was that the
one where they took out your dialogue
and it pissed you off
it's happened twice in english
out of my 36-year career i've been
dubbed over in english twice and the uh
the unfortunate uh misconception is that
doug always gets voiced over and because
it happened
twice and that's yes
the rest of my career has been my voice
uh and well you also put it into a
contract it's now a part of my contracts
right i will not i will not be voiced
over you got some clout in the industry
you got some respect maybe not or they
might say f you doug and then i don't do
the job so that's fine does that ever
happen no no ben kevin thank heaven but